[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club round six of the
Spring Classic here in st. Louis with
his rook bricked in on the back ranked
grandmaster alex ona shook resigned the
point to grandmaster Roman Edouard Grand
Master Jeffrey Zhang continued his march
as black beating us rival Grandmaster
bara Cobian for the first time ever in
Group B an unusual sight for decisive
games for black grandmasters Mika Levski
cocky on priyadarshan an international
master Stamboul AK were victorious with
group be a close race coverage of round
seven starts now with over 30,000
dollars and pride on the line twenty
international chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2018
spring chess classic
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for round number seven of the 2018
spring chess classic we're in the
homestretch my name is Ben Simon and I'm
without a name her and group a is
becoming the jeffrey zhang show real
quick in fact today he could
fundamentally ended not mathematically
but practically group b is a little bit
closer though a lot of things heating up
here of italian oh yeah I'm definitely
that's a lots of interesting fights
we'll see how they also doing in the
coop a now last night we had some
results let's take a look in the masters
division what happened last night yeah
so we had three drawers and the two
decisive games that we had a remain
Android a one with white against Alex on
me shook and Geoffrey Zhang winning with
black pieces for Vera Cobian that's I
think it's his first time if he beats a
version right our records show that
these two have met in classical games
three prior times two times were draws
and then vara copia had one win over
Geoffrey that was Jeffrey's first win
ever over his US rival and now that
takes us to the standings for group a
and man Vitaly what do you make of this
yeah as you can see almost no changes at
the top we still have Geoffrey alone
along there actually he was leading by
one point before that now he's leading
by one and a half point however we have
closed a close fight afo all other
places I mean look at it everybody
else's with three points and two and a
half points I mean I I mean yeah Jeff is
young is over there but everybody else
is still funny yeah at +3 like we said
if Geoffrey wins today that might wrap
things up yeah yeah pretty much it's
gonna be very interesting and this is a
yeah and last night in our challengers
division group be for decisive games in
blacks favor yeah it was a all-black day
over there just one drop between under
and JJ mirandy so Viktor Mahadev scabby
Towanda Liang AJ - tembu luck beat
action Chandra Malika can beat Aaron
Grove in ski and priyadarshan can athon
beat alexander fear and if you take
those four players who one is black and
switch out and blackburg orbits you'll
have the top leaders in this division
right up until now actually Chanda was
the one who was leading for the past
five rounds and now he's only not only
in fifth place but pretty respective is
still fighting for for one of the top
places but we are going to see what's
gonna happen today might decide or maybe
bring somebody closer to that
first-place prize now we hope that
you're watching on us chest champs calm
it's more than just the video you're
probably like where are the games well
they're already in progress you can see
the digital board at us chess champs
calm via chess 24 and let's take a look
at the games that are happening right
now online in the masters section only
one game has ended thus far four games
in progress right so we have a yardage
they're both playing against the Roman
Edouard
Jeffrey Jean playing at same Shanklin
I'll occipital is playing against
evolution a call girl so reactant gude
is saying as en masse old a thoroughbred
zone and again it was added in a draw
was between Alex Anisha and Dahlia
spirits the crucial game of this round
without a doubt has to be Jeffrey Zhang
vs. Sam Shanklin now these two have met
four times before there were three draws
two one win for Jeffrey
Sam has never defeated Jeffrey and like
we said a Jeffrey positive showing today
is gonna be very good in his favor
yeah it's going very interesting to see
what strategy is Jeffrey Zhang going to
choose today for his game is he gonna
build a more risky a chance just to
secure that may might be first place
today to try to beat Sam or is Sam going
to play more risky game himself as far
as I can see you know German both of
them are unbeatable as of
yes and when loser draws am Shanklin
will be remaining in town the day after
the tournament for a book signing he has
his book for sale and you can't really
get it anywhere online yet we looked we
tried we try that but he has his books
here for sale it's called small steps to
giant improvements Master pawn play in
chess and he'll sign that for you
on Thursday the 15th right here at the
club okay let's take a look at our
pairings going on right now in the
challengers division on us chess champs
calm yeah we have a biological pump
Lingus and regards medica gently in case
Alexander fear Jackson block playing
against Aaron Kavinsky a victim Mikulski
is playing as Archer chandra and JJ
Marathi playing against the Wonder Liang
and two of the leaderboard tops are
playing each other today we're talking
about Priyadarshan canna pan and Andre
Corbett's and that is our game of the
day our key matchup for Round seven in
Group E yeah both on earth with four
players so definitely the one who is
going to win this match will have good
chances to finish on the top seed the
tournament format is as follows
you'll be seeing 210 player around
Robyn's remember only three rounds left
the time control 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves after that each player
gets an additional 30 minutes added on
to their clock and there is a 30-second
increment from the very first move there
will be no playoffs in this event so if
there are two players or more tied for
the lead at the end of regulation they
will simply share the prize and be
declared co-champions and this event
also features the Sofia rules or the 30
move no draw rule where the players
cannot agree to a draw before both
players have made their 30th move and
that encourages fighting chests yeah
definitely and and metalbend here we
have just one round per day which gives
the opportunity for players to rest
sometimes as opposed to two rounds per
day but still I think that the last
three rounds are going to be
one who decide the winner of those both
tournaments however usually the last two
yahrens the players are going to be
slightly exhausted so we're just gonna
see who has the most dominant who is
more prepared today we might see some
Wars of attrition indeed and here's when
you can see those last rounds we've been
starting every day at 1:00 p.m. and this
was the last day we're going to start at
1:00 p.m. Central time tomorrow and the
final day Tuesday and Wednesday due to
Pro it with chess League that's the
internet chess League really cool thing
actually yeah they do the protest League
obligations of some of these players we
will be starting early 11:00 a.m.
central here in st. Louis and we will be
seeing you two and a half hour I'm sorry
two hours early ourselves at 1:30 p.m.
Central Time
yeah it's gonna be interesting to see if
it's going to affect the players you
know because some people are not really
mourning mourning persons right you know
like sometimes I remember myself when I
I used to wake up very late so that
might be truly for them but we'll see
how it affects them so yesterday we
dealt with daylight saving time and the
scapegoat that was the scapegoat for
some of the players being late there
were some players late but today there
were even more players late for the
round yeah so tomorrow it might come er
is not here today Tony Rich was up in
the tournament hall and he told the
players he was like we're starting two
hours early tomorrow be sure you're here
yeah if they're not there they have a
half hour to make it at a half hour they
default the game to their opponent so
and with chess club I mean it's not like
this is a huge open tournament if we
notice a player is missing we'll try to
call them you know wake them up you know
get over here yeah but if you can't do
it if you can't make it here have 30
minutes to default and they usually stay
pretty closely right I mean it's like
five minutes away so you know they do
need to go get them
we will the players are right next door
yeah they're in the neighborhood for
sure let's take a look at the prizes for
this tournament
our master section the most lucrative
twenty-two thousand dollars on the line
yeah six thousand dollars for the first
a second see that will go home with
$4,000 and the third place will take
$3,000 and you can see the rest of the
break-up no losers here to be sure group
B not too shabby itself 14 grand total
prize fund yeah $4,000 for the first
four top chess player at 2,500 2,000 and
again everybody gets a prize and you
know you know Ben
besides the the prizes that we have in
Testament sometimes it's not the most
important thing that we have we have
sometimes what we call calm conditions
and for example an interesting an
interesting event happened just a few
days ago in the candidate tournament in
Berlin I remember in round number one
Alexandra Grichuk was playing against a
Vladimir Kramnik he lost he loves the
game unfortunately and we're locking it
at least today he won his game
yesterday however the there was an
interview was made after the game at the
press conference and the interviewer
asked Alexander Grisha how is he
enjoying you know is is all conditions
are to his satisfaction and actually he
his answer was quite surprising he said
that he actually has no water in the
toilet in the hotel room oh no no no
that's very bad yeah so that that is
quite strange so I'm not sure obviously
he said in the interview that it
probably wasn't did not affect his
playing strength but you never know and
yeah so this is this is also conditions
are very important by the way how many
do we have here we have a lot and they
are all working and all the players are
quite satisfied and if they're not
satisfied we'll make it right just like
the car dealer thank you for that vitaly
alright let's get to the game shall we
okay so we have one game drawn so far in
Group A but as is tradition let's look
at the game of the day in Group A
between Jeffry and Samm
yeah that's let's see
going on here so far as I can see from
from the board we have a pretty equal
game going on so far however I do like
white slightly more first of all Jeffrey
has more time of the clock and Jeff is
pretty good in time management by the
way he I can't remember when was he in
time trouble however look look at the
pawn structure look look at the Queen
this this White Queen on a Foley
dominates she can go to h7 she is trying
to find a path here to h7 or five she's
also defending this pawn on d5 very
interesting endgame but the most the
thing that makes the greater change here
impact is are the bishops so if we look
at our bishops here we have dark square
bishop for both players however look at
the pawn structure black has all his
pawns on dark squares which makes his
bishop weaker and we know that in M
games we prefer to put our points on the
opposite side of a color of the bishop
so this is exactly what Jeff is doing I
mean look at his last move
he played b3 he might even play c4 next
move just just to make sure to put all
his pieces on all his pawns on white
squares and I wonder if you know if Sam
is really realizing that I mean he he
definitely wrote a book about pawn
structure so he probably recognizes the
difficulty that he has in this position
so if somehow black succeeds in
exchanging the bishop this would
probably be closer to an equal but I do
like White's position I don't really see
exactly how white wins this one you
probably will need to push the pawns and
try to get a passed pawn at some point
but I mean look at blacks pieces I mean
I don't see a space for this Bishop on
g7 I don't see a way for the screen and
d7 moving at any
so because if we move it let's say when
it comes to the six
this will allow white to bring in this
Queen inside and say hello to the skin
on f6 the Queen King will have to go to
move we are going to try start now
taking all those pawns and get cast in
blacks position so I really like
Geoffrey's chances at the moment how did
we get here
great question so let's see what what
has happened so far so d4 was tied 96 9
f 3 9 BD - okay that's an interesting
move other choice and the idea is
usually to play E for and now Sam played
Bishop to g7 just saying okay I just
want to play my Kings Indian the
technically black could have played
probably something like d5 and I wonder
if white can just play he'll see for
maybe it might an suppose somehow to
some groennfell defense
but we have some different pawn
structures here so I'm not sure so same
just decided to play whatever he
prepared for and now this position
actually looks kind of like a paired
defense of some people pronounce it
disappeared depending on their which
part of the world you are I know in
Russia we say periods we all know it's
actually period so there's actually a
book called Pierce alert and it's
actually meant to be pronounced perk
alert percolo yeah it's a birds Oh Burke
so 96 so we see some development
development of the pieces here some
exchanges 94 so far very balanced I
would say this position at least at
Queen e7 Queen 3 - I definitely like
White's position slightly more because
of this night on c4 but a few developing
moves Blankfein chato's is other Bishop
a5
we had a few exchanges Knight to d5 this
lady this one really shows me that
Geoffrey is trying to win this this game
very nice fighting spirit it does get
the two bishop advantage and now g5 now
this pin here although this h4 da that
diagonal is just too annoying it's very
difficult for black to to resist so he
plays g5 exposing his king slightly but
again why does not have a knight luckily
on that you can put on a5 so probably
the king is pretty say if it takes we
see a few exchanges and this is pretty
much how we got to this point structure
and f5 okay so so far in this position
same had this nice pawn structure I like
it but now white puts all his bones on a
white squares g4 I'm pretty sure I
wonder if sin did not expect this move
g4 really creating some imbalance here
on in this indestructible a this move 24
because if black white plays that's a
king g2 and trying to put his King on f3
then black would get the upper hand good
efore so Queenie 4 nice blockading move
although the Knights are usually the
ones are supposed to block it pawns
we don't have Knights at this moment so
we have to use what we got
king of seven king of the Kings are
coming into the game and let me refresh
my board and c4 was played 26 and now
White has and now it is white to move
here so as we said white put all his
pawns on light squares yeah yeah I don't
see a way that white can lose this
pretty much me I can just make some
waiting Moses just moving over his queen
around 23 24 23 24 and I think black is
going to suffer there are some other
options here 25 can come in
Queen h4 and y can also try to activate
this his bishop through h4 really
interesting position as you can see sam
is really trying to figure this out over
the board but the clock is ticking and
they are in move number 33 so still that
he hasn't it's not not such a big time
pressure 7 moves for 17 minutes so it's
about of the three minutes per move so
not too bad but I would I would be
always to start sweating if I were here
yeah it's looking pretty good for Jeffry
okay let's look let's look at the other
game of today in Group B we have Lea -
on Kalapana vs. Andre Gaurav it's two of
the four leaders they're playing each
other today sitting at four points
apiece yeah interesting position we got
here on the board so it's an end game
ninth versus Bishop but white is a pawn
up so far I don't see lots of
compensation for black for that pawn
obviously the black King on a5 is is
pretty active
I like the King on the five pretty much
all of all of the blacks pieces are good
if I were white I would think about the
world should I bring my king to e3 and
somehow somehow the problem for what is
that his pawns of a passive over here I
cannot play G for obviously because the
rook takes rook takes on g4 at any
moment so I think white will probably
play King III try to bring his King
somewhere maybe to d4 and then the idea
would probably somehow to activate his
Knight another thing that white can play
here is maybe to push b5 and just now
figuring out we just want to let black
to figure out where would he put this
Bishop is it gonna be somewhere here
only four but then he's gonna get
attacked by the King or maybe he will
bring it has to bring their Bishop back
in that case again I can move my King in
the King can go to d4 Knight goes to d5
and
yeah again this this position can be
probably only be won by white so it's a
it's for tourism being played for two
results and I like productions chance of
changes over here all right let's see
some some other interesting positions
Brazil and Brazil dominating here with
black against Ganguly unfortunately
those two don't have too much of a
factor in the standings of group a
anymore but it's worth looking at
yeah yeah of course so let's see what
what's happened here
so rope takes on e5 was played
interesting so right now we have equal
material actually no black has a pawn up
and now black decides to sacrifice the
exchange probably this is because this
night only if I was super strong black
cannot move any of his pieces I mean
this rope cannot move anywhere this rope
is not cannot move anymore the bishop is
tied up and the proper public is that he
cannot move the knight so for example
well would I move the knight maybe
Knight see eight or nine take c4 or
something like that but the problem is
obviously Queen takes f7 check so really
although black is upon up at this was at
this position it was very difficult for
him to make a to make a move so maybe
this is why Brazil may give it made a
very practical decision and took him on
a fire and now it is so yeah Ganguly's
move and he is thinking here should I
take with my queen or should I take with
my rook
interesting interesting decision if I
take with a queen then obviously we are
looking at night taking on see for next
move to the Queens under attack but also
the rook here is under attack what is
going on yeah this is this is getting
very complicated position let's try to
take with a rook instead then rook takes
in that case what else can we do again
but I can take on c4 probably Queen
takes d8 but we also lose the rook on e5
and this position is very unbalanced
black gets a knight and two points for
oak but don't forget that this this King
on g1 is much more exposed than the
blacking so always black will have such
checks on f3 and yeah I'm actually like
Lazaro's chances here this was a very
positional and excellent sacrifice
practically rook takes on e5 let's see
what how did he get this position we had
a 45 laughter 96 Bishop c4 Knight f6 d3
Bishop to e7 so we have the Goa Cup
pianissimo here
a very mild opening everybody's just
developing their pieces what is probably
slightly better than this position just
because of the position of the bishop
here on e7 but the bishop will find
himself spot in the future so we have a
few pawn moves white is placing his
roofs over here of d5 break with black
take take 90 X t4 and now white gets
this active play I wonder if what really
had to sacrifice and go Knight e3 I
wonder if we could just take on d5 here
and if Knight xt5 maybe Queen takes e5
maybe now would go back with a bishop
and just keep the material balance but
why did sacrifice the pawn here and this
is how we get to this position and black
took on a four got a pawn up and now
Whitely this was g4 Wow
g4 what was the I do g4
maybe g5 yeah because you know usually
when we just start to learn chess we
don't want to expose a thing so much
right right that's what I'm thinkin it
does those pawns next to the king when
we do bring those pawns up usually it
happens in an endgame for example we
don't have any Queens on the board or
other pieces and we're just trying to
get more space but in this case wife has
played the G for a very risky move very
risky and as you said you know if you'll
remember we were just discussing it
before but those two players need to
risk something to try and get to the top
right I mean I think it's it's just
fundamentally out of reach at this point
for both of these players but I mean you
saw the prizes earlier I mean you want
to get closer to the top right yeah yeah
even even the second place in Group A
takes like $4,000 so it's there's a big
difference between 4,000 and some of the
last prices which is $1,000 right now so
so g4 was a very risky move but I feel
like Brazil was prepared for this with
this move route xt5 are pretty shoes
pretty sure that so yeah I did not
expect this with this move route 85 so
yeah please do we start to see here some
fireworks and Vitaly I don't want to
alert all of the action genre fans but
elsewhere in Group B Victor mikhalev ski
as white against a shot Chandra let's
take a look it's not looking good for
the st. Louis --n let's see let's see
what is going on here
so right now it is Victor's move we are
at move number 25 as you can see Victor
has some time to a two minutes but
action china doll is getting to that
pride time pressure with seven minutes
which means that he has about he needs
to make 15 moves in seven
about half a move oh I'm sorry and move
in one minute with the increment so
let's see why to move here what do we
have so material company quality white
has a bishop for tonight which are like
this is a very strong bishop right now
the black wants to take this bishop
because they did not want to exchange
his minor pieces and I assume that I
wonder if Y can just play this most c5
we have already seen a few moves that a
few games well this seaport was a passed
pawn and made it all the way down and
got a point for the player
I only wonder if Black has some chances
like rook takes rook to e1 check King to
g2 and I'll go into a1 is there anything
here to look for for black that is the
question you know how scary my of those
are those threats so root G one is
coming the Queen a for checking h4 and
then g5
interesting so maybe this is probably
what Victor is calculating among do I
need to be scared at work that's let's
start to check here on v8 and now the
King has to go to h7 and now Queen to f5
check he has to play g6 and now he can
take here on f6
not eco the whole question is can black
check with him because if that does not
check with in this position we're gonna
have some checkmates on there change so
let's try this road you want check King
H to check here and let's see where can
I go with the King King age for the only
check black has is g5 and now if I go to
h5 then Queen h3 checkmate so that will
be good
King g4 black has this move Queen e2 so
it looks like this was this was pretty
good what if I go to g4 immediately now
if Queenie - I'm gonna have f3
h4 h5 here and now was making going
probably to h4 yes I think no I'm sorry
now after King h4 Queen takes h2 so
where can I go the king if basically if
I can escape with my King and I can
cover all those checks the white is
pretty much winning it's just this one
of those you know inevitable mates on h8
let me try again
King g5 not only check it I see is on
III and now Bishop to f4 so I see no
other checks except we can just
sacrifice all of our pieces and this is
the march of the King and yeah I think
that Viktor really has enough time to
calculate this variation but
to me it looks like just push this pawn
push on c6 is pretty safe I wonder if he
is calculating anything else obviously
if he does not want to get into this
variation you can also play something
like Bishop before just going back
defending against this this invasion of
the rook on to e1 so black can only just
check once
kingi - and why that's pretty much safe
however in this case may be but I can
try to play a 5 attack our Bishop on or
before in that case rook to who can can
go to East to a7 but yeah I really like
whites whites chances here let's see how
we get to this position
Victor started with the c4 and 9 f3
directly defense d5 and b3 interesting
g3 and we have the double fan shadow
pawn takes on d4 pawn takes on d4
Bishop to d6 d3 h6 980
King we have a castle look e1 so very
very balanced balanced position few
exchanges here Queen a5 I do like
White's position slightly more white is
putting some pressure here on the B file
and and on be 7 and yeah so it looks
like white is slightly better got the
edge there's a few exchanges Bishop
takes d6
and this is pretty much how we get to
this position and yeah even in this
position if we just go back a few moves
like try to play 90 g4 with the idea of
Knight e5 obviously white cannot take
this time because of twin takes b7 so it
tries to play 95 great move by Viktor
this move Bishop to d6 basically
preventing the knight from coming to e5
because take take and obviously Queen
takes an f7 and we're gonna get to a
checkmate and Vitali
I hate to interrupt you just saw on the
camera a couple players walking by with
score sheets
that's Mellie katya and alexander fear
who have drawn their game in Group B
hachi and of course was one of the top
players the top four that has four
points now he has four and a half so
live scannings he's in the lead so
that's where we stand on that
all right perfect and yeah so but for
sure he won't be alone at the top
because we have paired I'll show kind of
behind the gore of its yes and one of
them will get some points and one lives
yes
okay so yeah so I really like Victor's
position here let me just refresh to see
if we had any movement and it still
seems like it is Victor's Victor's
decision to make as I said c5 is on the
is playable for white or maybe just lit
it with a bishop oh maybe Bishop e7 by
the way if with no plays a Bishop e7 we
might see a repetition of wolves after
Knight g5 g4 but I'm pretty sure that
Victor will try to play for win so we
will see how that game develops Victor
of course is won his last two games so
he might be building a streak here
Oxshott is trying to right the ship
after losing yesterday - she didn't
block no and of course actually had that
great start to the tournament they went
to it oh I believe the first two rounds
yeah it was him
yeah so yeah so we'll see as you can see
not only how we start matters but also
how we finish finish line some people
like to Springs over the day crossing
line okay let's look at some model games
let's go to group B I have so Group A
let's see
Kogan yeah yeah it's having a cope in
that position sorry about that this
position proud it looks pretty
interesting to me okay okay just just
one thing stands out this queen of a
chase what's the opponent h7e played
each a tempo volunteer queen probably
not but how how did that Queen got to h8
that is that is the question of all
questions you haven't learned the
ancient chess rule of teleportation
okay that's official it's coming back
yeah I see so the Queen just teleported
to h8 well even if she did I'm not sure
if it's the best Square for her
questionable teleport yeah well she she
is spinning the bishop here on g8 she is
putting some pressure on g7 however I
wonder you know the king is defending
the bishop the rook is defending on g7
and now basically for my standpoint this
queen and the stroke are able to create
some chaos but I'm not I'm not so sure
what is going to going to happen I think
that will on move number 23 a lot of
things are going to be decided at the
time pressure I'm even though it looks
like an equal position in my opinion
it's not going to end up in the draw I
mean just this discipline on each it is
just it's just to imbalance I'm not even
sure who is if it's an asset or
liability let's let's see real quick how
did we get to this position we start
with D 496 we have the Queen's Indian
now returns also the Queen's in Queens
gambit the client this is just one of
the main lines
a few exchanges here oh and Queen King
to e7 that is unexpected
so you can't cancel anymore why would
you play King e7 that is a good question
let's try try to defend in other ways
okay Bishop to d7 comes into mind what
is the problem with this move
oh yeah let's try to make some crazy
sacrifice at stake Bishop takes on b5
I'm going to take here on the f7 check I
and now maybe this is the whole point if
the King takes on f7 Queen to b3 check
and I'm gonna get my bishop back if I
don't take the pawn and I play King to
f8 then I still have it this form going
to c5 I assume I'm still gonna get this
Bishop back so in this position can he
play this stage of King d7 well in this
case I have Queen f5 probably and I
think that King c6 will probably be too
risky to risk that that'll be too much
to put the King on c6 so maybe this is
one of the reasons why evolution did not
play which would be 7 obviously if night
goes 37 then probably politics only 6
and if I take this pond and queen g6
check lots of lots and lots of troubles
here for black I'm not sure what if this
is one of the main lines or what went
wrong but definitely this King is 7 move
surprised me know in this just limit we
actually do see lots of games without
without castling yeah that has been the
case yeah
I think any special we were about that
and all that we don't allow drawers in
the first Olivos but do we also don't
allow casting in the first 20 moves or
something pawn takes on d5 Castle Bishop
e6 brookie120 693 it looks like the
white is develop his pieces much better
96 but the question is how can we get to
the skin on these seven pretty quickly
and I don't have the answer it just
looks like those two bishops on e6 and
f6 they're doing such a good job and
let's see what happened Bishop takes
Queen takes 95 Alex on the epitope is
definitely doing the best as you can to
expose the black King rook takes and f6
who goes back and now AHA so this is how
the Queen got to h8 Queen to h7 once I
take on g7 King f8 Rho G 3 H 3 and queen
to h8 very interesting choice yeah this
is hmm this is definitely one of the
turning points y2 really has to figure
out do I want to put my queen or h8
although oh I can come back maybe it's
similar to a 5 or g6 interesting choice
by Grandmaster epitope queen h8 26 Roxy
one of c8 we had a few moves and now we
are at this position that will refresh
my board and black has white 23 and we
have 86 on the board mmm let's try to
find a plan for white white move
you can see the both of those players on
the screen right now external epitope is
trying to figure out a way plan how to
play next but yeah they have nine
minutes and a carbon has eight minutes
and only 25 moves well played
they're definitely going into time
pressure epitope has played roof to f5
Vitelli you said you weren't sure if the
Queen was looking good or if it was a
liability based on where it was I don't
know how it could be anything but a
liability is the Queen just I mean it's
in another universe it's dead right now
is there any rebuttal you can offer to
that statement yeah I actually I
completely agree with you when I said
that the wide stroke was on g3 before so
I see that the Queen was putting some
pressure on g7 at least Stein up some of
black's pieces to the g7 pawn but now
once white moved a6 and rook to f5 where
the Queen is not ever going to to make
any escape so basically is the king and
the bishop has almost captured
restrained the Queen on h8 very very
interesting position I don't really see
how white can manage that however if you
see white made this very tricky move on
his last move rook to f5 and the idea is
that white is actually wanting to take
on d5 this bishop is after all pinned so
it will be interesting to see how black
is if and how black is going to defend
this pawn let's try to figure out an
answer for black
it is actually not so easy how do I
defend this spot well I can defend it
with the rook from this side but that's
not going to help me I mean if I'm going
to sacrifice my queen the problem is
rook c8 coming in and that is pretty
deadly what is going on who is better
today five how do I defend this
okay-y question yeah why if I move the
Ruby back and you're gonna take with the
rook maybe I can set the sack to my
ropes to get to this position how do I
get the Queen out can i second fice here
on the six take take and the Queen takes
h6 okay if you're gonna see this
variation that's going to be the decade
crazy prediction by me but obviously
this is gonna lose at least the Queen
anyway our four points Queen the four
pawns against the bishop and the black
has no chances here whatsoever but again
this is gonna be pretty exciting to see
how black defending is defending against
this threat of rook takes on d5 okay
let's move to some other games that we
haven't looked at yet what about a one
delaying against JJ morandi groupie okay
yeah I know that I wonder he's not
having the best tournament of his life
here right now but let's see if he can
make a comeback right now black is it's
pretty equal but black has two bishops
advantage of two bishops interesting
endgame I do like his Queen here King
him on their five as we said that
because it's an endgame we do want the
key to be active and on his last movie
did play this move g5 which which makes
me question can I move h5 how are you
going to stop this pawn over here that's
a really strong passer
how do I stop the spawn okay maybe black
and played this world g4 and that is
that why if white plays this movie h6
now Bishop takes h6 and rook takes h6
and now black has this sneaky move rook
to d1 the back rank mate usually when we
see back rank mates all of although the
pawns are restricting the king but in
this case this Bishop is doing the same
job so maybe this is what a wonder has
planned it is a one whose move so let's
see what White has played a white plate
instead he played Bishop to e7 and this
is move number 37 they just need to make
two to three moves to get to the to the
10 control to get another 30 minutes so
what can black do here this night and f8
looks a bit strange I gotta say again
I'm not not sure if it's if it's so good
or if it's bad
let's try to exchange groups and see who
will benefit from this take take take
I might have a check here start mate
what I might take on f6 this looks not
not too bad for white
that's too bad so we do have a wonderful
thing a move and he played group to d2
we know that in the Indians we want to
place a roof on the second rank or
seventh rank in this case
rook to d2 attacking the g2 pawn also
probably the idea of is for black to
bring his bishop to d4 and also attack
the b2 pond so for example in this
position if it would be black to move
let's say white tries to play h5 I think
after Bishop b2 those three pieces you
know playing together their coordination
is super strong that's pretty hopeless
for for white so white really needs to
figure out well how do I defend against
Bishop default yeah rook takes on g2 is
not the main threat of this at this
moment so how do I defend against Bishop
before that is a good question I can
give a few checks let's try to give a
few checks g4 King f4 96 but
unfortunately every check that you that
you're going to give is actually gonna
help my king go forward and just snap
all those pawns and I still don't see a
way how can we prevent Bishop to d4 yeah
I think overall the game was pretty
equal but as you can see when time
trouble comes in and then the this is
where we have the blonde goes
in the game I wonder and JJ actually met
last year at the Spring Classic this is
the second annual that was at the first
annual the colors were reversed and
wandered to defeat him that was the year
that was the event where a wonder won
the so the defending champion may be
repeating with the colors reversed we'll
see yeah but right now let's let's take
a break and when we come back we're
gonna have a special guest and much more
analysis right here at the 2018 spring
chess classic as the st. Louis chess
club celebrates its 10th anniversary the
US Championships returned to st. Louis
for the 10th straight year
this April America's best players
descend on st. Louis to plate for the
country's top honor Wesley so and sabina
Foy's ER will be defending their
championships as they face an all-star
field
don't miss America's best battle it out
at the st. Louis chess club celebrating
10 years of promoting teaching and
playing the game of chess for tickets
and more information go to st. louis
chess club org
[Music]
you
[Music]
a question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like PA 3
is an illegal move here because white
advances pawn to squares not one but it
still is something we call hustle and
you can do that but you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a moment
I'd let's say play King in seven games
e2 and now try because y'all played four
against Lawrence and now he's going to
play something against me which we
discussed the playing during the course
of my steak yeah he told me this is that
g5 this was what I was kind of hoping
for because now I think he practiced I
know who Lawrence this is not how it
works
certainly would be much much more fun if
chess actually work like this I don't
think it does well maybe it does well
that's me regretting what I just said
how did I get from there to here is a
little bit beyond me and what's worse I
will never hear the end of my quality of
life has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
of the guy
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to
another portion of our show today it's
the midst of round number seven here for
the 2018 spring chess classic I'm Ben
Simon and I am here with the father of
Geoffrey Zhang himself Wang Zhang nice
to talk to you sir thank you for joining
me thank you for having me van and you
and Geoffrey are quite the chest
tag-team the people who have been around
here in st. Louis for quite a bit always
seeing you two traveling together tell
us about how by the way I have to tell
you Geoffrey Zhang did just draw his
game during the break with Sam Shanklin
so we can't see him in the tournament
hall we were all ready to put them up on
the screen right now screen right now
but that is the game is over
how did you in Geoffrey start your
adventure into chess all right so it's
solid when he was 5 years old and you
know that when the kids are young we
have this birthday parties from one
kid's house to the other and one of his
Burst Apart is the one of the boys
I brought a chess set with him and
Geoffrey went over to grab these pieces
because it's a very funny you know 3d
horses and castles and figures exactly
that's right and the day he went over to
grab the pieces and then the other kids
said that no that's not how you play you
need to have a poor they give me to set
up like this and each piece has a
specific move and Geoffrey's eyes
started to shine and very interested and
then after the party he said dad can I
have her a toy like this and I asked how
much is it and they tell me it's about
10 bucks
okay I bet exactly I spent ten bucks to
buy him very settle with her towards
that man and that's how you got started
so well the Jeffrey is he's 17 now right
nothing so he has been making the rounds
all over the chess world in 2016 perhaps
his when he made the biggest splash won
the Junior Championship right here at
the club junior US Championship
and then went on to win the World Junior
Championship so now he's one of the best
players in the country and the question
I have for you is is it innate talent or
is it hard work which is which is
Geoffrey basing his excellence off of
was it was he born this way or is it
just the hard work he puts in so it has
to be both in my opinion that he
definitely has their personality the
talent that he can do chess that he is
very focused always very concentrated
when he is solving the problem like when
he was young he was doing those puzzles
there there the the the jig puzzles
exotic support yes that's right and he
was very good at that and then when he
played chess he would be able to sit
there and for a couple of hours that I
would say that his concentration is
better than the average kid and also
it's a lot of work so but he is really
passionate about chess he loves chess so
the hard work does not seem to be too
tired for him so he can play blades with
his friends on the internet he can solve
chess problems with his coaches and with
his chest friends all the time yes so
they were having a lot of fun so it's
not too hard to get him to work long
hours and chest and that's what it takes
it's all about dedication do factory
Geoffrey is one of the youngest American
grandmasters of all time and that is
quite the accomplishment in and of
itself
are you a chess player Wayne yes I can
play a little bit chess because you know
you were to support him I have to know a
little bit chess but I'm sure that
I'm not as good as you
oh the people up online are lighting up
the comments oh I don't know it might be
a good match she's activating one of
these times that's right you can't
really hold down a traditional
nine-to-five if you're traveling with
Jeffery so often what do you do for a
living tell us about your background
okay I have always been in finance I
used to work for Citigroup I actually
had to travel to here because I you used
to work in the mortgage business of
Citigroup and there had a quota of city
mortgage is actually you know Fallon so
which is about 30 minutes from here in
the metro area
it's the mazury mazury mazury O'Fallon
and in those days I would drop Jeffrey's
year and I would go to the office you
know Fallon and then I certainly
realized that a regular nine-to-five job
you know will not allow me to travel
with Jeffery all the time so therefore I
have been working a financial soup
brokerage business on the sidelines and
then later on that the business in the
brokerage part has been growing very
nicely under and so I was able to just
retire from sinking and that I don't
need to hold a regular bridge of anymore
and this financial brokerage work is a
lot more flexible so I have got my team
here and then we have actually opened
the three offices in the state of
Missouri just since 2012 that was the
first year that Jeffery I need to come
here to play in US Junior Championship
so so with
traveling to the newest right now it's
about half a dozen time every year and
each time it's 1015 days so it has been
very nice that you know I can actually
do a lot of work here so you have been
seeing me a drop Jeffery's year and then
I disappear and then I came back and
then did Jeffrey happen and there were a
lot of very nice restaurant in this area
so I actually have a lot of clients and
team members that come over to visit me
here so I take them to that to the
restaurant around Starbucks and got a
lot of business done so it has been
really nice to be able to without
sacrificing my career and also being
able to support Jeffrey yeah that's
actually an amazing situation that you
can put yourself into to accommodate
Jeffrey who is quickly if not already
depending on a definition a world-class
player and right now he's poised to win
Group A of the spring chess classic we
always we know in life in chess and
everything that fathers have a lot to
teach their sons and mothers have a lot
to teach their sons have you learned
anything from Jeffrey because of his
phenomenal chess prowess Oh a whole lot
I would say their most wonderful thing
for the last that's about already you
know more than 10 years of this journey
is that we as parents we grow with him
together and that you see for example
that at the very beginning when he came
over to play the US Junior Championship
for the first time he was not a
contender at all and there every year
you know he improves and sometimes there
is some up and down you know take two
step forward one step backward and then
until 2016 he became the bass and he won
it and also for this tournament that
their classic it was the same that this
is the his third time to
participated the first time he was
having a negative minor score and he was
close to the bottom of the lineup and
then the second time he got four point
five out of nine so he was in the middle
of the pack
now this time you know of course the
tournament has not finished yet but
looks like he's going to be able to
finish in the top half of their
tournament
so therefore to see him grow and in the
meantime you know we as parents we grow
and during the process we screwed up on
a lot of things and a little from it and
very so gradually that we were able to
do it right so therefore I still expect
that it's going to be a really long
journey but it's just a lot of fun to
have us to grow with him and grow
together and totally enjoy it
Wayne thank you for joining me and do
appreciate it and we look forward to
seeing how Jeffery finishes this
tournament out and also upcoming in the
u.s. championship next month so it's a
lot happening here let's take a break
and when we come back we'll have more
analysis here at this brain chess
classic a moment comes in chess when you
need to test yourself at a different
level chess twenty-four premium offers
the tools that you need to reach your
maximum potential from hundreds of
interactive video lessons to becoming
part of the chess 24 community you can
analyze with friends or coach your
students live you get twenty four by
seven coverage of chess news and events
access to premium analysis and
commentary and the chance to interact
with grandmasters and other top players
and coaches get it botched from the best
and even challenge them to a battle be
the best chess player you can be it's
time to level up your game with just 24
Premium Membership
as the st. Louis chess club celebrates
its 10th anniversary the US
Championships returned to st. Louis for
the 10th straight year
this April America's best players
descend on st. Louis to play for the
country's top honor Wesley so and sabina
Poyser will be defending their
championships as they face an all-star
field
don't miss America's best battle it out
at the st. Louis chess club celebrating
10 years of promoting teaching and
playing the game of chess for tickets
and more information go to st. Louis
chess club org
[Music]
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mine art experience
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
twenty four premium offers the tools
that you need to reach your maximum
potential from hundreds of interactive
video lessons to becoming part of the
chess 24 community you can analyze with
friends or coach your students live you
get twenty four by seven coverage of
chest news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership I'm Mike
Matheny whether you play chess for fun
or want to boost your child's academic
performance come visit the Chess Club
and scholastic Center of st. Louis right
here in the chess capital of the u.s.
from a welcoming diverse environment to
a Scholastic outreach program now in
over 100 schools our Center across from
the world chess Hall of Fame the Central
West End has it all so whether you've
played for years or never before we
invite you to experience all chess has
to offer
[Music]
and welcome back to coverage of round
number seven of the 2018 spring chess
classic I've been silent and now I
thought I'm a mur and we want to thank
Wayne Jean for just coming on and having
a really great interview that was really
insightful they tell you yeah yeah
definitely I mean I have some so much
respect for all those parents who devote
so much time to the kids I remember them
with my mom and my dad also used to
drive me everywhere I mean it's very
time-consuming it's a lot of effort
especially you know for him he is also a
full-time job I do I do know that I have
a few students coming new to me
and they always ask me especially in in
Wayne's age and they always ask me am I
too old to start with chance I might -
also become a grandmaster and I think
the big answer is definitely now no I
mean we see we have seen so many players
today got to be grandmasters I mean
Geoffrey Zhang and one delaying a just
in five years they they pretty much
became again masters and yeah I think
that actually me I'm waiting for
retirement because I know that once I
retire and I will have all this time on
my hands free vote for chess and that's
where I'm gonna get my game more so yeah
good Feingold's record oh yeah game a GM
at the age of 40 if there's a record for
the for the youngest GM there should be
a record for the you know the eldest the
most senior GM right well and there's
there's a caveat there because you know
a lot of people are awarded the Grand
Master title if they win like the world
senior championship or if well the
original class of grandmasters they
didn't get the dorms they were bestowed
the title so I'd be interested to see
lighted up Internet
how many who the oldest grandmaster is
who want it with the current regulation
system the three norms and the rating
qualification right right I guess
the sixties are the new for these 60s a
new 40s okay so let's let's take a look
at it Jeffrey's game he drew Sam right
as we were coming on with his father
yeah yeah definitely and I actually had
at the time to globsters and to speak
with also those players they were just
analyzing their game and I know that you
know I was I was telling that I was
really surprised to see a draw because I
thought that white was much better and
said yeah Sam said yeah I was dead lost
I mean he was pretty disappointed of how
he played the game but he saved it the
game so so so good for Sam and yeah
Jeffrey even even the draw would
probably get him closer to that first
place I don't know who can without a
doubt that's let's see what happened in
the game
we stopped pretty much over here Queen
went to h7 attacking this Bishop at AU
Queen a5 check a king e for so okay I
wonder about about this this idea quick
King before it looks like I'm improving
moving my king same ID as in an endgame
probably the ideal Jeffers idea was to
play key Queen e6 check exchanged the
Queen's and then bring the bishop over
here maybe to take this pawn or get some
advantage but I wonder that maybe he
forgot about this maneuver from black to
play Queen before and now the black
Queen is the one who gets very active so
I'm not sure maybe maybe in this
position
maybe White has some ideas like h4 or
queen h5 it definitely looks like a
white was better at some point at some
moment and then after king e4 we have
some checks King coming to a5 very nice
technique King Queen takes on v3 and
Eastern mate King g8 Queen a check
this is where the game ended in a
pathetic eventual check can I make any
progress King g8 can I move a king
forward I'm going to lose this policy
for you Queen f7 check it's still just a
perpetual check I really this this
Bishop on the floor is unfortunately too
passive so I definitely think that Jeff
Lee had a chance here but but I think
that you pointed out something very
interesting that Jeff Lee actually won
all his games with the black pieces yes
he his dad was down here and I said Oh
Jeffery just drew his game he said did
he he cannot win is what exactly so then
all of his wins have been with black and
it's true this has been an unusual
tournament as far as you know White's
white seemingly has no advantage in this
tournament you know yeah yeah very maybe
maybe Jeff Lee has to when he's playing
white maybe has to come to the board and
just play something like eight three oh
h3 just a black right it'll be
interesting to see
okay so let's jump to some other games
we I do know that we have some exciting
games going on and I do know that and so
yeah Ganguly want a bit bruised own I'm
sorry
bruise own was the one who beat so we
are gonna go Leah okay yeah this is
actually what we saw in the game and I
was saying that black has captured here
on e5 kwinto 2592 e4 this move I did not
consider I thought that black would take
this pawn on one c4 I guess I'm I'm a
pawn grabber myself just like a yes sir
but a knight Knight to e4 and the idea
is that I want to take this pawn on f2
and if the now if the roof takes on d8
Queen takes here on f2 pretty much
everything is falling apart I can take
the stroke I can check on on on g3 a
very bad position for white so white has
played Bishop d2 Knight takes
g5 now wow that's that's a hit for the
White Queen obviously the White Queen
cannot take on the two because if the
rock is defending the night Queen went
on the five we saw in the exchange of
queens ruled Italy and then black just
improved this position and finally
played this move Knight to f3 getting
out of those pin and now if white takes
on d4 Knight will take on d4 and Black
has two pieces and upon four oak and the
circle really has nothing to do I mean
there's no way white is going to defend
this pawn at five he's going to lose
another pawn and usually in such victory
collapse key has just defeated
Akshat Chandra all right in a end game
with a few ponds and a queen versus a
rook there were promotions all around
the place yeah so Oxshott falls at the
hands of the cholesky may collapse key
is on fire
it looks like makovski with three wins
third in a row yes Wow which puts him on
the first place now it would be yes that
that is the case first place in B yeah
with five out of seven wow what a change
in action will probably go to number six
from first place to sixth place okay
yeah action sitting and even score right
now three and a half let's see how the
game ended we finished we looked at the
game at this moment that's when we left
we said that the bishop can either go
back or white who plays c5 he did play
c5 obviously this this pawn on c5 is the
ace of the game this is how white is
going to win
Queen étude was played King G to a5 rock
a seven so we discussed that the roof is
coming here behind the pawn to control
that pawn queen a5 Queen c2 Bishop e7
lots and lots of pressure here on the
King on the King side
Queen b3 and now black had to give up
this Knight pawn takes on f6
and Queen takes on d4 and basically why
this controlling everything he's
controlling the pace of the game 80
black tries in the end he tries to to
make a run for it with the apron but I
really don't see how it is possible
because the Queen here is defending the
square the row Casillas defending this
square so why just snap this f6 pawn
threatening a mate by the way so this is
why we can't just play a - Queen a
checkmate black I had to play King to g8
and now c6 ok so now we're gonna have a
race between the C pawn and the apon a C
and unfortunately they cannot keep
pushing the pawn it Red Queen takes d3
okay so still Black has some chances for
perpetual check maybe check here check
him the white king is slightly exposed
but Victor found this accurate move
Queen to c6 I really like this move it's
defending all this whole diagonal not
allowing black to get any checks it is
attacking the rook on the e e8 and it is
supporting the advance of the pond to c8
we saw Luke c8 rook a8 and basically
this is almost lost for black left try
to defend and cling b7 very accurate
obviously black cannot take the rope
because of a check and we promote that
the pawn queen b7 King h7 Queen takes
the 8 quintic c8 rotates it and black
did get the Queen first however just
just a quiet move a quiet move which
finish the game the idea is that now the
rook is defending all those key squares
and probably there is no perpetual check
up I assume that the rookin could go
anywhere he wanted to maybe even two
eight as well but basically after this
there are no chances for perpetual check
let's try to make this move Queen B one
Queen
check here King f1 and if life tries to
check from here well eventually the king
will be escaping over here and together
with the Queen and the rook he shall win
the game so yeah pretty good game for
Viktor
let's look at another game let's look at
what about a wandering we just left it
when we had to the rope coming to d2 and
we had lots and lots of exchanges they
did make a time control which which gave
both of the players another 30 minutes
for the games right now black it has a
piece up against for a pawn and I can
see that this Bishop is attacked
I wonder if I wonder if wonder is
looking for you know changing the bishop
or or moving there are lots of options
here for black how can white how can
white managed to make it draw well just
sacrificing this Bishop for this
opponent believes will not be enough I
mean you know mating with two bishops
against the King is pretty easy much
easier than a bishop and a knight so
that will not work just coming here and
sacrificing the bishop however if white
succeeds in exchanging one of the pawns
for the pawns then Bishop and versus two
bishops that's a pretty easy endgame I'm
not sure if I'm not sure if black can
exchange bishops let's try this can I
exchange bishops after what this pawn is
not an edge pawn so I don't really care
about this square but again the question
is about this pawn here so let's try to
figure out what it is a wonder thinking
about oh I think I saw him almost make
him over here
I'm not sure if it was attached move or
not but yeah he did
well don't forget that it's everything
everything is being a coder right yes
you can't just touch a piece of thing
okay no I changed my mind because my
opponent is not there and obviously we
have the arbiters walking around and
watching so you got to make sure that
you that you make made the move end
and Wanda play the move Bishop to f2 he
decided to keep the bishops on the board
keep keeping the defense here over this
pawn on b2 and I I suppose white will
try to push his pawns before a4 and try
to push a 5 and the fourth black to
exchange this pawn on d5 don't be 6 I'm
sorry and but if even if it does black
can always play something like b5 and
once I put my pawn on on on light square
it's only very very difficult for for
white to take advantage of this pawn on
d5 so let's look at some other games
that we have here one giveth we haven't
nothin we did not look at yet is Aaron
Levinsky versus Jackson black looks
pretty equal as of like now we're
probably going to see some porn
exchanges over here let's say Y takes
here Knight takes probably I used to
like white before but now I really like
that because of the activity of the King
here on g5 he can come here to h4
starting and putting some pressure on
the h3 pawn the rook can come here on e3
checking the king yeah so I actually
pretty I already like blacks position so
maybe why does not be to take here let's
try to figure out a different boat maybe
something like maybe something like
Knight to d3 so yeah it's gonna be very
interesting for us to see how that game
will unwind and right now we have a
special guest with us and Sam Shanklin
welcome to our show hey guys how are you
doing I'm good I survived today which I
was not supposed to do if then working
hard I haven't even found time to shave
so I look like a hoodlum
okay you know I prepared very hard for
this game and this person moved to all
of that went out the window
I was hoping to have some chances to
play for a win because Jeffery was sort
of killing the tournaments and if I
wanted to have some chance I had to beat
him but this stuff to do with black so I
was hoping to play combative chess and
well he plays something quiet and really
outplayed me and I'm quite lucky too
yeah yeah it looks like he surprised you
in the opening so after the fall and I
see Saturday night of three came so yeah
I mean I checked the London system
already for honest trick as well as
Bishop g5 but Knight f3 Knight bTW - I
hadn't looked at I mean I know that I
mean black is obviously fine but I
didn't remember like all the right ways
that you can play like d5 before I think
that's was kind of my ideas you could
just play d5 but they probably can play
c4 b4 okay plays like Bishop b2 III it's
it's pretty famous system I know black
is fine I just didn't remember how I
know perhaps he's prepared something
here it's some new idea I didn't really
want to find out what it was so I played
d6 and Bishop g7 any suppose in the 15
cm right DD - I mean it's Plex
definitely fine I just handled the
position for
I think yeah because of the night on the
to it mo looks like a pure color person
we have this argument with then how do
you have the you pronounce appear
corporates I never acquired such an
opening all right c3 and I knew he five
was the move and I knew he's good I knew
that he's gonna take and that it's a
little unpleasant for black but it
shouldn't reason realistic way should be
okay but the problem was like I didn't
really want to play five but I couldn't
figure out like another sensible moves
like my everything in my position is
screaming play he five and I considered
like playing this weird setup a6 b6
Bishop d7 which actually is not so
stupid but I think he can go like rookie
one night F one night g3 and at first I
remember checking these positions and I
couldn't find a pawn for it but then I'm
when I figured out you should be playing
in charge five I realized it's a bit
unpleasant so beast b6 and Bishop d7 oh
no mines me is it that kind of like the
heap oh I think that's usually with the
Knights on b7 e7 yeah yeah I think you
should play a six first just to not
allowed to five but looks passive a
little bit yeah maybe it was a better
choice practically than what I didn't
ever had any kind of chances but right
so ii five yes d65
yeah after they change of the knights
the position wasn't so bad although just
a little passive so queenie to and
Jeffrey told me after the game at night
h5 is the man I was aware of something
like this but it's a little bit
complicated I just stopped putting my
pieces on good squares like can't be so
bad for black but I was very wrong about
so he prepared up with you at this point
so he I'm sure he referred further than
this I mean okay Rick do yet it's hard
to call this move a crime I'm putting a
piece on a good square of course Bishop
she sort of was zoned out a little
because the position seems pretty dry
but after Bishop wish for b6 it occurred
to me I may just be losing the game
immediately to f4 like for the life of
me figure out what I'm supposed to do
about e5 coming next nasty taste and
just computer seems to think I'm okay
here I couldn't figure out how
was right hmm no I mean I was I always
have compositional of two pawns in a
nice structure I was calculating like
Bishop c4 after 85 for example Queens
too - I thought I had to like take on d3
here which that's correct
yeah pretty sod quindi three and Queen
d7 is the move Queen d7 okay this is
what I was calculating at least quit do
797 okay for Bishop e6 exchanged on but
I'll win one pawn back I've got a very
solid structure decently active pieces
right it's it's definitely unpleasant
it's not like I have to resign but it's
I'm going to suffer a long long time
something better than this but I was
worried decisions decisions just decided
to play safe actually heating platform
yeah I think what's still a bit better
the way he played of course when I
played h5 I completely missed you can
play Bishop c4 because now I no longer
have this g5 resource and here if I
played Bishop takes before he goes
Bishop d5 and I'm losing material well
it's it's a jungle right so I had so I
played Bishop h6 it occurred to me here
right after I moved I might at first
when he played Queen f3
he could play Queen f3 when I first
instead of f3 you can play Queen f3 and
when I first saw this I thought okay
King g7 I checked to make sure I wasn't
losing losing to any tactics but then
I'd only occurred to me after I moved it
if he plays like
h3 I'm kind of in this one I like just
move a single piece yeah I said this
through Connie oh they hate to but
someday he will play g4 right he will
prepare it accordingly maybe play like
King h1 or something in them G fort and
be ready with g h5 and roof she won and
it's yeah I'm not just in big trouble
here just can't can't move this but this
palm backwards
big decisions has some small steps and
big that big in Bank impact
so Bishop h6 f3 alright so this so I
thought was okay I took on d1 and then I
was explained was ripped he it was I
thought that it looks like I'm kind of
getting crushed by Bishop d5 but my
point is I have this surprise instead of
have a surprising tactic after a bishop
t5 mm-hmm I can play Bishop takes c3
Queen 83 there's 55 and he should
probably take f6 because if he plays eg
my big idea of rip takes d5 and all of a
sudden he's been tricked
nice nice endgame of the pulling up okay
maybe he will hold this bishop to it but
it's holding but it's lots of
calculations but 95 was just a better
move and at first I didn't think this
was so dangerous because the way I
played made a lot of sense but like
after Bishop takes d5 I mean I didn't
really want to play against the bishops
it's not so bad like if I play like King
g7 for example say Bishop b3 rookie 121
there should be 3 he's got to play King
I flung because if King h1 I have 94 so
and say I played Bishop c5 and just
stick my Bishop on d6
yeah it's unpleasant it's very hard to
suggest a plan for whites and yes I mean
eventually he can try to get before in
but g4 and risky
well it depends for example G for you I
mean I general I think it's the wrong
plan but also here I can probably just
take it with the Knights oh right
all right now not quite than I didn't do
one just loose at the end but like yeah
looks like you're holding like a
fortress or something maybe but like if
he gets before in it's going to be very
difficult
yeah the biggest problem was a time
trouble right the time travel yeah I
made a point to play quickly just
because I know that Geoffrey does really
well when his upon certain time pressure
that's how it wins a lot of his games
right so but I probably should have done
something like this because when I
played g5
I only considered Bishop III like it
seemed to me so automatic for what you
provoke the Ponte ish for and here I can
take on d5 and I think black is okay
because he cannot take with the rook
this is very important I'll take him for
the Quincy fire
check right so he must take with the
pond and when I first saw the position
after pond takes d5 I was quite worried
but then I found this very nice idea
Bishop g7 to defend my pawn queen e4 and
now Queen d7 he could not take on e5
because of murky gates and once I get a
five then I think black should be okay
right so but the way he played was just
much stronger after Bishop f2 Knight
takes d5 rook takes d5 takes f5 I had
seen this position that I when I was
calculus the move g4 just completely
didn't occur to me yeah I noticed
I actually I was watching live and then
I said they probably missed this little
chief war it's it's hot to move I saw it
before he played it but not before
playing a final look at this point I
don't think I could have done anything
about it anyway because he was going to
play G for nourishment here I think I'm
just busted yeah I was trying to find
somebody offer resistance and this is
just really bad so Queenie for it but he
played very well so I like the setup I
wanted to get was Queen d7 King f6
Bishop d6 I thought if I get this I will
hold
I didn't see an active plan for him I
can play for Bishop c5 next right and
it's hard for him to go through the
properties I don't think I can get there
so the way he played was quite good
Kings you too it's very strong that he
played edge three because if he plays
King f3 I can play like c6 or c5 or
something
so edge three first King f3 yeah and the
problem is here after I was already bald
this move King f6 well it kind of forced
0.05 as a thrust I mean it was just the
setup I wanted was king f6 to the bishop
yeah you will not skip over h4 for him
at some point well I was but I didn't
think I could do much about it here I
thought h4 was not so great because
after GS for Bishop h4 king f7 if he
plays Queen a5 takes takes Bishop f6 I
believe is a draw at least I couldn't
find a win for white here I will bring
my king to d6 and then place to five I
think it's the drop so so down what I
realized was when he just played b3
keeping it nice and simple that if I
played Bishop f8 to get myself now he
will play h4
okay because now I cannot take it
because d5 hangs at the end right so I
just could not actually get this set up
yeah and after so I've done what I've
liked hanging seven I think this is just
absolutely hopeless so see for Queen b6
yeah I won that say again did he play in
the game h4 or never did yeah I don't
think it's necessary I think what he did
was absolutely fine c4 was just so I
played Quincy six just begging for some
kind of counter play but yeah Queen h7
is very strong king f7
we're not five King G it and I believe
he can just play 26 and I can resign
right I think I mean the son game is you
have to think yes well I can't give me
six of course it takes and I just
couldn't find if you place d5 next I
died so I have to play either bishop of
thing Fisher of a favor c5 myself
neither of which hold so if there's a
fate before he actually there's an
interesting movement the machine should
suggest Bishop oh yes sorry
because Bishop before he has to start
with h4 before right King before on the
point is now if Bishop c5 just takes
takes h5 in the pond Queens so thanks
and then e 78th yeah no I mean but if
Bishop c5 instead of Jewish for then
after takes the point is that he has h5
and his monstrous Queen right so and so
this is the key move for him was
basically h4 as far as I suppose the
spot this move at some point I just
couldn't find a defense after it but I
mean there was more to it than that but
it's it's just lost after King you for
Quinn before I think I have a fair
amount of counter play I was very
surprised when he tried to make me with
kwitny six and ki5 I just could not
believe this would work I was expecting
him to play queen c8 instead and just
take the pawn on c7 I know I thought it
was very important that I play Queen G
to hear anything at this it looks like
angels for him well do six
and quintics of 2j7
I thought king g6 was holding because it
makes a quintuplet cringy to King Day 3e
for mate which I thought was kind of
nice it's a nice me right after king g6
the problem is if he doesn't win it
takes me one move to play Bishop f6 just
give this bisher for the DuPont then
white is lost so that's it's very close
but I had to play Queen d2 and take on
f2 not even so much to take the bishop
just to get the G to score for my queen
so he played 26 26 King edge 7 King f5
so he's trying to like bring the King to
f7 and make me but I just don't think it
will work
Queen takes b3 I mean my bishop is a
very good defender and yeah like if he
plays King e6 here I mean yes you just
probably take on yeah I mean I have to
be a little bit careful for example
taking h3 kind of Lutz why show his idea
after Queen e8 king and queen king f7
and now I made it but if but I had I
think any number of ways to stop this I
could have taken on c4 so that in this
position I will have Queen takes d5
check I could have taken on a4 so that
he doesn't have 28 I just I did not
think he was particularly close to
mating me so as long as I was reasonably
careful so here I guess he forced to
draw because all of a sudden he's I
actually have counter play and he's upon
down and so I I was quite fortunate to
draw the skin nice nice well
congratulations it looks like h4 this
low but yeah good good for you that's a
that's a palm play and I know that you
just came up with a new book that's a
mind our viewers kind of wanted them
some look backwards those bonds are all
on the wrong squares yeah small steps to
giant improvement and I know that you
are actually going to have a book
signing over yeah I'll be giving a
lecture and book signing the day after
the front March 15th at 6 p.m. here at
the Chess Club
you cannot yet buy the book online but
you can come and buy it from me in
person so yeah and I will sign it for
you so I was trying to shoot to bite the
vine I didn't find it anywhere but it'll
be out in a couple weeks online but for
now these are pre-release lectures you
get the first look if you come out and
see the lecture all right perfectly I'm
gonna
be there well Sam thank you so much for
joining us and good luck in the rest of
your just a moment thank you and we are
going to go into a short commercial
break break and they stay with us
afterwards as the st. Louis Chess Club
celebrates its 10th anniversary the US
Championships returned to st. Louis for
the 10th straight year
this April America's best players
descend on st. Louis to play for the
country's top honor Wesley so and sabina
Poyser will be defending their
championships as they face an all-star
field
don't miss America's best battle it out
at the st. Louis chess club celebrating
ten years of promoting teaching and
playing the game of chess for tickets
and more information go to st. Louis
chess club or question on Twitter from
dem s I should not have pronounced that
that was a bit of a trap here
for those of you who are new to chess it
might look like ba 3 is an illegal move
here because white masters pawn to
square is not one but it still is
something we call on tassel and you can
do that you have to do it instantly you
can't wait for a move like let's say
clay King in seven kimchi - and I'll try
because y'all play four against Lawrence
and now he's going to play something
against me which would discuss the
playing during the course of my stay
yeah he told me this is accent g5 this
was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think he practiced I know
who Lawrence
this is not how chess works certainly
would be much much more fun if chess
actually work like this I don't think it
does well maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of my quality of life has
just gone downhill tremendously because
I'm actually sharing the office with the
guy
[Music]
hello and welcome back to Round seven
coverage of the 2018 spring chess
classic this has been Simon a man
without a murmur and if we want to think
see I'm Shanklin for coming in you know
that book signing on Thursday that's a
pretty big deal
it's his first book says jokingly those
might be his last
no after today you know the pawns are
moving backwards on that he wishes but
with thank you for joining us of course
we still have four games going on one
game in Group A eat the table and a Kobe
on it looks pretty good for version
mm-hmm and then we still have three
games
oddly enough going in B but our time is
winding down vitally important yes I'm
functioning we'll have to get throwaways
again yes I feel tomorrow yeah it's so
far with just one game remaining let's
take a look at our live standings for
our masters division and Jeff Jones
still leading with five points and
everybody else is pretty much living
with three and a half points so close
match we probably Jeff we will clinch to
the end to the first place but it's
still very very open for this for the
other places second place it fell place
yeah I mean Jeffrey is basically gonna
have to go over to these last two rounds
to not win so I don't think that he is
going to risk anything tomorrow to be to
be honest I mean just making two zeros
would be enough for him yeah yeah low
risk Danny do we have standings for
group B lovely let's see them Group B
standings this is live which I mean get
what you can out of these we still have
three games going yeah so we have victim
collapse key at the top with five points
we have Malika Jian at the second place
right now and then we have priyadarshan
come upon playing against Andre Corbett
with four points and it looks like it's
pretty equal but I I suspect that this
game is gonna go for a while
while priyadarshan has he's having a
porn up in the dead end game I'm sure
that production is going to try to fight
for win using that that pawn to get to
share the first place all right well we
thank you for joining us today here in
st. Louis for coverage of our classic
this event was brought to you by the
world's greatest production B team Tammy
Hyde is back making sure the stream is
healthy today Jonathan France is our
interview manager Isaac Krantz is on
graphics and sound our technical
director is danny Machuca my name is Ben
Simon and I am forth on a namer and we
want to remind you that tomorrow
everything starts two hours earlier the
round will begin at 11 p.m. Central
I'm sorry 11 a.m. Central Time and we
will see you at 1:30 p.m. central 1:30
is when our video coverage will begin so
until then we say so long from the
show-me-state
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you
you